Це макет автомобіля «жужа». Саме так, лагідно,
військовий лікар Всеволод Стеблюк називає медичне авто,
на якому з іловайського котла він вивіз
87 поранених.
А це фото тих, кому врятуватись не вдалося.
Три роки тому під час виходу з оточення,
влаштованого російськими військами, Всеволод втратив
шістьох товаришів.
Вони тут, щоб нагадувати постійно,
і я з ними спілкуюсь, щоб ми не розслаблялись і щоб довели нашу справу
до перемоги.
Загалом під Іловайськом загинуло
366 українських солдат,
429 отримали поранення,
а 300 потрапили у полон.
Головною причиною, що призвела до численних жертв,
слідство військової прокуратури України визнало агресію російських регулярних військ.
Також зазначається про низький рівень боєготовності Збройних сил України,
численні факти дезертирства та окремі помилки
керівництва АТО.
Втім з поправкою, що вони «не перебувають у прямому причинно-наслідковому зв’язку
з настанням тяжких наслідків – загибеллю
українських військових».
Полковник Володимир Шевченко називає такі висновки
однобокими і сумнівається в незалежності розслідування.
Він нагадує про відсутність наказів Генштабу
і дезертирство конкретних генералів.
Всі знають, там три чотири генерали було,
які тікали,
встановленими місцями.
А інші люди: і полковники,
і командири бригади, виходили через цей котел.
Експерти звинувачують ГПУ і в маніпуляції цифр,
зокрема співвідношення військових сил
України біля Іловайська та російських
солдатів і бойовиків з так званих «ДНР/ЛНР»,
на їхню думку, не могло бути 1 до 18.
Якщо вірити цим даним, кількість російських військових під Іловайськом мала би бути
кілька десятківтисяч осіб, хоча в тому ж таки повідомленні
йдеться лише про 3,5 тисячі російських вояків».
італій Погосян «Правозахисна група «СІЧ».
Нічого не вказано і про помилки керівництва
Збройних Сил України.
Віктор Муженко залишається керівником Генштабу.
А тогочасний міністр оборони Валерій Гелетей
нині очолює управління держохорони.
Не було масових звільнень через тактичні помилки
і на нижчих щаблях.
За звітом військова прокуратура
допитала понад півтори тисячі потерпілих та більше
двох тисяч свідків. Втім, Всеволод Стеблюк сумнівається у
безпристрасності слідства і суду.
Рік тому, саме під іловайські дати, його нагородили державною нагородою –
Орденом свободи.
Та на справжню відзнаку від держави .
полковник медичної служби ще чекає
Іловайськ не повинен зараз згадуватись,
це така офіційна політика.
Чому?
Ну визнайте, що це трагедія, але це героїчна сторінка нашої історії.
Всеволод і досі продовжує їздити в зону АТО.
Після іловайської трагедії він створив перший в Україні
центр психофізичної реабілітації та написав книгу.
Всеволод присвятив її загиблим друзям у так званому
«зеленому коридорі».